so designing tables is hard
i
was not prepared
for that
did you notice that this data set has
got like tons of like missing stuff in
it oh all through it it's like
i'm looking around is there any data
around i'm just seeing n a's wherever i
look it's like i'm in a world of n a's
when i look at this data
but you got some good stuff here the
stuff that's not at a
[Music]
i don't think you're ready for this i
think i'm ready what
it looks really good i can read the code
sort of
what
this is looking great so it took me a
while to get to like what like like you
said right like what is the data
is there like data here and like how do
i put it in a table
um yes and i definitely approach this of
like oh i use the tidy verse so my data
should be tidy and then my first table
was just one long column
and i was like oh yeah it's a common
mistake you don't want to be tiny when
it's tears like if your table is too
long you're not yeah it's not useful
yeah exactly and like it should be like
it's almost like you're reading in a way
like you're gonna make it ready for
reading and for a person to read not for
a computer to read yeah if that makes
any sense i think it makes sense yeah
uh but this is straight how did you
choose the colors
okay so it's always a hard thing for me
i always like experiment with a million
dollars i just don't i can never settle
on stuff so this was a process so i
decided i was going to look at tax
status of california newspapers
and then i was like california makes me
think of like summer the beach and kind
of like the the vaporwave aesthetic
yeah okay i was just saying that these
are very vaporwave colors like with
salmon you got like you got like that
blue
turquoise
yeah so
i went in and i was like
i so i looked for um
vaporwave palettes basically i pulled a
color palette uh and i used that and
then what's really what i really liked
about the color palette
is with the scales code here
um
so when i was doing when i was using
this for the color palette you kind of
give it your uh
i don't know your markers right like
here are my five colors but then
because it is
in
interpolating i guess or interpreting
yeah it isn't true it actually isn't
yeah so
yeah just like
in a graphics editor those are the marks
like the
like the interpolation points i guess
you can say like you color yeah so it
was great because like when i first got
the table and i got the columns colored
i was like oh this is so much better
than just the palette because i'm
getting that range so then what i did is
i went in
and i used a color picker in the browser
to take
um i think it's like this color here
and then i set the alpha to be really
light because it looked funny like the
white wasn't a right color for the
background
and then what was really cool
i mean i learned so much doing this but
being able to
target all of my nas and have a specific
function
to turn anything that was in n a
a specific color was really really cool
because it was like it was cool now it
like my nas match the background and
it's not gray it's not like i mean like
this is a jarring table this red is
atrocious
um i like it i like it too but like it's
not like it's not um
you know to critique my own table the
colors aren't informative right like
1977
is not a dangerous number it doesn't
need to be very red right compared to
the 70s it should be like purple blue or
something like that yeah
yeah like you know
yeah like i may be reversing the color
palette or things like that but what i
thought like what what i took away from
this was how you can actually surgically
select colors in gt
and yeah that was what
i think
um
seemed like it would be really
challenging and was probably
oh
i think it was probably the easiest
thing i did was just be well besides
like pipe gt was like oh i want to you
know as long as you know what something
is called you can target it with a color
which was yes exactly super cool uh did
you do that can i see the code for that
yeah so data color did one thing but you
did also okay so you did for
different columns right yeah yeah years
of operation you're founded
great
yeah it's kind of neat because i guess
you have to do it that way because like
there's different like domains right
yeah we did it like all together it'd be
like
sort of messed up because the data is
like different so
yeah so that was that was fun um
yeah yeah and then so like that was
where the font came from
was because
i was google font okay it's a google
font so i was like i don't want to
deal with downloading fonts i don't want
to leave for font today
um you know like use the fonts you have
so i was like what's this is like
because everybody can use this font
right yes yes internet access it's kind
of like
super simple yes as long as you have
internet access you can you too can use
this
incredible yeah
by far
just have internet please
i feel like you do a really good job
with footnotes and source notes and i
just wanted to try them
yeah if you don't work then like at
least you tried i tried that's pretty
good because you don't have like a huge
huge table so you can get to the bottom
without like scrolling forever yeah and
it was just like yeah this is missing
data
so
but yeah yeah and then because of the
calls we've done i was like i can use
markdown so i would yeah it's awesome in
these tables like look at that you just
put some
links inside yeah which is great put in
some links i was like yeah let's let's
let's get wild here so this one but like
it was it was one of those things where
gt i think is deceptively simple because
sitting down to do this i was like i'll
be able to knock this out in like 20-30
minutes
yeah and then i was like you could but
you could you know it wouldn't be like
this it wouldn't be like this yeah
yeah so it was it was really interesting
and like just you know we've talked
about a little bit about like preparing
your data for a graph or a plot is very
is different from a table but also then
i was like what would even be
interesting for a table right because a
table
you know you're not necessarily creating
a table for the same purpose as a um
as a plot right i don't want to like
average everything and only have six
rows i mean you you have tables where
you want that but i was like no this
would be like an overview so like how
granular do you get with the data yeah
it's like almost like it has like the
same number considerations but they're
totally different yes
yes
[Music]
okay so we have links they're nicely
styled
is underlined it's not right below the
text it's a little bit further down i
like nice links it's also colored in a
way which is not defaulty okay because
who wants to faulty okay so i'm going to
click on it
and it opens in another tab
check that out
and it faithfully opens up so this is
kind of like a little catalog for these
cool hubs
that you know like people have been you
know like looking at in this data set
wait so
what i'm missing
is you're going from that like nice
summary table and now we're scrolling
down what can you go through that like
real quick like can you show me again
what is how does this work
okay uh okay the trick
having a frozen header and a frozen
footer yeah is to make multiple tables
three tablespoons out it sounds nuts but
that's the only way you can do it
because like every other way is like
prone to failure so these are multiple
tables
yes sort of like
you know blob together with instrumental
tools okay so there's a div here there's
a div here another div not the div
so it's like three dips within a div
uh but yeah this middle div is like
basically the body and i've hidden the
cone labels you can totally do that you
can just see there's another option in
tab options just like call labels hidden
true and then it's gone the only okay
the only major thing you have to do and
this is like super super important is
you have to set the widths of each
column okay in each of these tables
otherwise it just fails you just get
misaligned stuff and
it'll just look horribly bad
um
but uh that said
this is a pretty simple table besides
that
but i did a lot of prep stuff so i read
the table that's no big deal i put that
in one file because i didn't want to see
this again so just working
fine okay
another kind of thing cool thing i did
is like there's lots of different places
that these papers come from
or publications so i went to like uh
this census page and i tried to like
have groups of students okay so i
figured you know what you know had to
have some sort of like groupings so i
did like this like west midwest south
northeast canada because you know
there's key stuff in there too uh and
these are like maybe dubious groupings
because some people will say that these
are not actually the sound but
that's what i found in this publication
so i'm just sticking with it um so i
have all these states
and the cool thing i want to do is if
you know this here i wanted to group
them together otherwise they'd just be
like sort of all over the place right
you'd have like
you know i wanted to be in a certain
cluster of you know like the same
publications or publications within a
certain state within a group which is
you know south midwest so on so forth
first of all all the urls didn't look so
great yeah i didn't even know some of it
didn't work i went through a process of
just checking each url i made this
function
it is a valid url so basically i'm just
you know and it takes a long time
understandably because there's lots of
these and it has to check each one and
make sure it returns to 200. okay so i
check all these and then i just filter
and i say okay i do this it takes like
20 minutes okay super long time i just
went away and then i just sort of like
wrote it into an artist file read it
back again it's like a checkpoint never
have to do it again
okay and then i do a bunch of link
cleaning get rid of like the https get
rid of some other craft that's all the
place some of these like links like lead
to like donation pages or like contact
pages or abouts it's like
oh just give me like the base url so
it's pretty careful with my g subs here
to just get rid of stuff that was safe
to get rid of
okay
and then uh yeah a bunch of arranged
these factor
to make sure that these uh states
were all in the same order as here and
then
yeah i just capitalize a few things you
know make sure it looks nice i change a
few things
you know for profit just fp
i like the short forms it fits nicely
and then uh yeah languages i notice
there are some like inconsistencies
there i just cleaned it up
either en or yes
and i made the table
so i made the links obviously like right
here
you know like this i used publication
name the cleanup url i made a pattern
that made the link from html if you use
calls merge and you make a pattern this
is not escaped so you can basically use
this as html that appears
it's like a little bit of a loophole but
i'll take it so basically this is column
one this is column two repeating column
two again
because we're just taking the link and
uh making sure it works and it's like
an anchor tag
so that's great um in calls label gotta
have it to do this stuff
super important if you want to start a
table which has tons of content and
other
table bits around it you just set the
widths of each column
as long as you have a few columns and
you have everything you're guaranteed to
have everything
set with so it's like you know it
doesn't like change with the content
it's basically what you don't want
i use lots of these opt functions as
youtube as well like um
you know all caps for giving this cool
look around um
like some of these names are super long
so what i've done was uh i've targeted a
bunch of these that were had lots of
characters i just guessed you know i
just tweaked this number
and basically if number of characters is
beyond 30 we'll just change the letter
spacing make it a bit more tight this is
like turning but not official turning
for the font it's basically like
this works every single font same with
the url those are even longer in some
cases even though it's smaller so i cut
off 75 i made it even tighter in some
cases
yes that's what i did there
and i even like fooled around a bit with
some css this is how i changed the uh
the links to be just a bit less defaulty
and a bit nicer i just changed the color
to be dark cyan okay and this
really hard to find parameter text
underline position under
s makes it so like this line the link
underline is a little bit further away
from the text that looks nicer i do i
like that it's this is like publication
ready you could put this in a shiny app
i think i could right i'll get away with
it too yeah like you could put it in a
shining up so now you're taking up a
very specific amount of space
but you're still getting that level of
interactivity with a scrollable table
exactly it's all about the dips like
anything's work within divs
um so let me show you like the other
thing i did which is the top part
so what i did was i um i realized i had
to like
split it up otherwise i'm just not
working just be terrible
uh so what i've done is i took a lot of
the code that was up here in this like
main table
uh but i took the parts that i needed so
here's a little trick here's a table
with no rows but has the same columns
you kind of need that right otherwise
you can't do any of this stuff like
without it uh so i just copied that
stuff made calls label change
like that that's the same
i guess i didn't need it above because
okay i basically just want to hide it
so let me show you the thing where i
hide it uh it's basically um
oh it's not in here i do the next the
next one okay
there's more there's so many layers to
this like it's like an onion which is
like a huge enough so as many layers to
peel back
so basically uh so this is the same
stuff as about there we need calls with
just like before i put this on there
because this is essentially chrome that
goes on the outside so you need to have
this you need to have a table font you
need the alignment because that affects
the alignment of these as well
and then on the next page which is
basically sourcing in everything that
came before that
which is basically those objects
i'm now using html tools and divs to
create the different parts
so
basically three divs inside one outer
div the main thing is that you just use
tags div
and then you put your content in and the
key way to get your like your gt table
content out is just use as raw html
at the very end
so this makes something but this dumps
it as html and this is totally cool with
it like this will just accept html
i like that so you don't have to write
so like let's unpack that for a second
you're saying you don't have to write
any html to get html tools to recognize
html
yeah the key thing is just like
outputting it as html if you just use
like the gt table object right now it
doesn't recognize it as having interest
and also it's like
what is this so if you just do this
you're cool and another cool thing you
can do is
see the div we have a comma pass the
html content
there's no argument there bigfoot style
argument and then you can use this
helper function html tools called css
and it just helps you like like write
the different style rules for the div
like the inline styles
um which is kind of a second set the
overflow this is actually super key
i need to have like the height 500 px to
make sure it does this
and you have to have these overflow
settings set up like this auto so it
scrolls and then finally let me show you
the thing i did oh yeah right here
column labels hidden so we did that
because we took that newsworks gt table
and just you know tweeted it so it
wouldn't show the column maples again so
if you scroll to the very top of this
it's not repeating this
right it's just like
the table part like the body part and
yeah that's the only tweak i made for
the body just making sure the column
labels are hidden i did the same thing
you can just take the top
uh so i called it newsworks gt pump and
then um i basically just made that
hidden as well
and some first notes and then like the
same thing i ended off with the raw html
and then i got this at the bottom
because that's in another div yeah
i didn't have to style that
but then at the very bottom there's a
style like block and this refers to the
outer div like the very first one okay
it got confusing with all the commas
everywhere uh but this is basically the
style for the entire div
the other div and basically i just made
an order i put some background color
inside
pretty nice you can use this wherever
it's just like on color names yeah
just for fun just remember remind me
that i still have this function it's in
gt so i did a bit of that made the the
order you know thick enough and looks
pretty sweet
[Music]